herr schreier ihrer erfahrung nach was
ist premier putin für ein mensch was ist
sein weltbild was sind seine
denkstrukturen ich denke aus dem was wir
jetzt in dem interview gesehen haben was
man aber auch aus früheren interviews
von putin sehen konnte es ist ein sehr
rationaler mensch der kühl analysiert
nüchtern die argumente abwägt schaut
auch rhetorisch sehr geschickt ich
möchte aber zugleich eigentlich davor
warnen und finde es auch problematisch
den konflikt zu sehr zu personalisieren
also diese fragestellung auch der
heutigen sendung wie tickt putin sie
eine fragestellung die sehr präsent in
unseren medien hier ist eine zeitung
versuchen das zu ergründen quasi ins
gehirn zu schauen und emotional zur
kindheit von putin und so weiter gibt es
ja ganze menge argumente
ich finde dieser konflikt ist doch
komplexer und er hat andere ebenen die
man eben auch anschauen sollte und sie
nicht zu sehr auf diese personalisierung
gehen
leider wird die geschichte doch von
menschen gemacht und bin ich dann nicht
einverstanden ich würde sagen drei
faktoren die putin ganz wesentlich
prägen
zum einen die kindheit wo er sehr viel
mit gewalt zu tun hat es in der gosse
aufgewachsen
der vater hat ihn verprügelt und er hat
selber gesagt er hat da gelernt dass es
nicht so sehr auf das recht ankommt als
darauf stark genug sein um das recht
durchzusetzen sehen wir heute
zweitens ddr waren während klassische
sträucher in der ddr hat diese befreiung
versäumt für ihn war das eine
katastrophe
die kleine heile welt in der ddr ist
zusammengebrochen und ich glaube er baut
heute ein bisschen wieder ddr in
russland und das dritte ganz
wesentlicher ist glaube ich kgb dass er
hat ihn geprägt sein großvater war koch
bei stalin und in dem interview hat er
zum beispiel gesagt wir hatten truppen
auf der grimm vor vier monaten sagte er
genau das gegenteil wir haben keine und
dieser umgang mit der wahrheit dieser
kreative umgang
ich glaube den kann man nur verstehen
wenn man diese kgb geschichte von ihm
ansieht
schreier das was der putin biograf
gerade eben gesagt hat und ein artikel
aus der welt von vor kurzem von jörg
eigendorf der auch in moskau lange
gelebt hat im sumpf der halbwahrheiten
ist putin meister was sagen sie als
putin verstehen anführungsstrichen zu
solchen vorwürfen
ich würde sagen man muss auf beiden
seiten die halbwahrheiten sehen
natürlich ist putin ein stratege der
versucht seine interessen nicht seine
persönlichen interessen wohlgemerkt
sondern die interessen russlands die
artegic verstanden als letztlich ja doch
gewählter präsident der mit einer großen
mehrheit der mit einer großen mehrheit
der bevölkerung losgelöste mehrheit ich
denke seit laut aktuellen umfragen ist
seine zustimmung irgendwas bei 70 80
prozent der bevölkerung im moment also
er hat schon einen großen rückhalt in
seinem eigenen land bei seiner
bevölkerung der versuch die interessen
russlands zu vertreten natürlich sehr
geschickt natürlich im einzelfall auch
mit halb verhalten aber man muss auch
schauen wo sind die halb verhalten auf
unserer seite sag ich jetzt mal auf der
westlichen seite und lassen sie mich das
vielleicht ganz kurz diesen kleinen
schlenker erlauben weil auch die
ankündigung der sendung damit begangen
es begann mit der annexion der krim so
wird wird wurde unsere sendung heute
angekündigt und dann möchte ich kurz
widersprechen es begann etwas vorher es
begann mit dem gewaltsamen machtwechsel
in kiew am wochenende vom 21
zum 23 februar damit begann eigentlich
die ganze eskalation und dieser
machtwechsel in kiew war natürlich
verfassungs ein verfassungsbruch nach
iranischer verfassung ganzen kleinen und
sinn also das ist nun wirklich unsinn
es gab eine abstimmung im parlament mit
überwältigender mehrheit den neuen
regierung bestätigt wurde das stimmt
nicht auch mit der mehrheit und mit den
wahlen meine frau ist lehrerin weiß von
den kolleginnen wie den wahlergebnisse
vorher schon bestimmt werden
die ergebnisse seien solche haben sich
russland gelegt sprechen sie russisch
sicher die analyse von spiegel online
die zwei wochen im moment die zwei
wochen nach dem gewaltsamen machtwechsel
in kiew veröffentlicht worden es bei
spiegel online wo ein rechtliches
gutachten quasi gemacht wird und wo
gezeigt wird dieser machtwechsel war ein
verfassungsbruch der ukrainischen
verfassung und natürlich ist jetzt
lassen sich vielleicht im moment kurz
ausreden
es ist natürlich so dass der rechte
sektor der gewalttätige rechte sektor im
hintergrund aktiv
also es gab ja die vertragsvereinbarung
vom 21 februar wo frank walter
steinmeier und die außenminister polens
und frankreichs mit janukowitsch und der
opposition ein abkommen geschlossen
haben dessen inhalt war dass man einen
soften macht sechs sage ich jetzt mal
über die bühne kriegt dass janukowitsch
nur bis ende des jahres präsident bleibt
und so weiter und nur einen tag später
gab es diesen putsch im parlament
mit der deckung des rechten sektors der
also zugleich gedroht hat wir machen
jetzt wir machen einen sturm auf das des
präsidenten gebäude die auch am nächsten
tag passiert und es war ein putsch und
der wurde akzeptiert von auch von
steinmeier dennoch einen tag vorher
genau das gegenteil verhandelt hatte
und das ist für mich der sündenfall der
europäischen diplomatie und dass darüber
nicht mehr geredet wird erschwert das
verständnis des konfliktes sehr bald
schluss dass meine ganz verzerrende
darstellung dann merkt man auch dass in
dem land offenbar nicht gelebt habe weil
die rechtsbrüche hat ständig
janukowitsch begangen und das ist
genauso wir nicht sagt bei tesco oder
bei honecker
das war ein putsch gegen honecker sie
müssten mal in diesem land gelebt haben
wenn sie verstehen der rechtsbruch ist
dort alltäglich von den mächtigen
ausgemacht worden ist wird er auch
aussehen und und die menschen haben sich
dagegen gewehrt und zwar friedlich es
wurden hunderte erschossen
es war ein friedliches es war ein
friedlicher machtwechsel und dafür hat
putin solche angst dass die leute über
ihr schicksal entscheiden und das also
nicht mehr von oben bestimmen kann und
dass es ihm nur um sein land geht da bin
ich überhaupt nicht einverstanden ich
glaube es geht ihm um seinen kleinen
macht prügel der unvorstellbar reich
geworden ist und die einfachen leute
leiden und leiden und 3 kurz ein haar
steuer direkt dazu ein durch gerne auch
demokratien gründlich weil sie sagen ja
auch soll um die sache gehen aber auch
um die person überleiten ich möchte nur
kurz ein haken weil das ist ein
wichtiger punkt den sie jetzt so im
vorbeigehen angesprochen haben das sind
die die das massaker auf dem majdan am
18 bis zum 20 februar gab es ja diese
scharfschützen massaker wo nach
verschiedenen berichten zwischen 50 und
100 menschen erschossen worden sind und
zwar auf beiden seiten also sowohl
aufseiten der demonstranten als auch auf
seiten der sicherheitskräfte und der
eigentliche skandal aus meiner sicht und
aus der sicht von vielen anderen ist
eben dass dieses massaker bis heute
nicht aufgeklärt worden ist das ist der
eigentliche start ist uns der
entwicklung danach kam die annexion der
krim oder die angliederung der krim je
nachdem welches recht welche rechtliche
auffassung man hat und aber dieses
massaker muss aufgeklärt werden wenn man
diesen konflikt verstehen muss nicht
behindern würden dann wäre es mit
sicherheit auf glaube die beiden
positionen sind jetzt klar